les accusations sont particulièrement
graves dans un article publié le 26 juin
le new york times affirme que la russie
aurait offert des primes à des insurgés
en afghanistan afin qu'ils tuent des
soldats américains
une unité russe est particulièrement
visée les etats unis ont conclu il ya
des mois que cette unité russe qui a été
relié à des tentatives d'assassinât et
autres opérations en europe ayant
l'intention de déstabiliser l'occident
ou de prendre sa revanche sur des
renégats a secrètement offert des
récompenses pour des attaques réussies
l'an passé des allégations qui repose
exclusivement sur des sources anonymes
pour la plupart issus des services de
renseignement américains ces sources
anonymes souvent désignée par le terme
officials sont cités à 19 reprises dans
l'article sans que l'on puisse savoir si
une même personne ait mentionné
plusieurs fois
au final seuls deux citations sont issus
de personnes clairement identifiés
dmitri peskov porte-parole du kremlin et
zabihullah mujahid un porte-parole des
talibans qui réfute totalement les
allégations des services de
renseignement américains expliquant
notamment que les talibans opéré par
leurs propres moyens pour mener leurs
opérations d'assassinats depuis d'autres
médias ont repris en choeur les mêmes
allégations affirmant être en mesure de
confirmer la véracité de cette affaire
peut-être ont-ils eu eux aussi accès à
des témoignages anonymes venant de
sources issues des renseignements ces
mêmes sources qui indiquent que le
président trump elle est au courant de
cette affaire
le principal intéressé lui s'en défend
personne ne m'a briefé ou ne m'a parlé
le vice président mike pence ou le
directeur de cabinet marc meadows à
propos des soi-disant attaques contre
nos troupes en afghanistan par les
russes comme cela a été rapporté par une
source anonyme du new york times fox
news tout le monde le dément et il n'y a
pas eu beaucoup d' attaques contre nous
donald trump voit dans ces allégations
une énième volonté de lui nuire à
quelques mois de la présidentielle
américaine d'ailleurs les démocrates
joe biden en tête se sont rués sur cette
affaire pour accuser une nouvelle fois
le chef d'état américain de collusion
avec la russie et c'est vrai que le
timing
ces allégations a de quoi interroger
alors que washington a signé en février
dernier un accord historique avec les
talibans qui acte le retrait de ses
troupes d'afghanistan